[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back we're here with the
Fantastic Daniel Radcliffe I'm having
such a
bucket list moment in life with you you
know my daughter came up with just a
scroll of excuses to tell her school
today to get here I think she did they
work I was like we no your school called
me and said you're not allowed to miss
any more days and we're in our November
and you started in September so we're in
trouble okay fair enough well I'm sorry
what's he doing his name her one is
Olive and one is Frankie Hello Olive and
Frankie oh my God
you have no idea the prop okay great all
right thank you for making me the cool
parrot just now it means so much to me
here's your water Cheers Cheers um okay
so we started as kids yes you know and I
like I
I was reading about you and and what I
was picking up was like an a CREDO and
an ethics and sort of a moral compass
for you
um it started to come out in the form of
like if people thought you were Elijah
Wood you would say oh okay yes because
you didn't want to correct them well
there was that happened a couple of
times well there's yes you just don't
want to ruin someone's day exactly so I
was like oh my God so people will call
me Demi Moore that one's weird to me
though you don't look alike I've been
Elijah would look alike I think it's the
names they're similar I mean they have
more in them yeah exactly that's I I
don't know I'll get you know I loved Jew
and Poltergeist or another movie I
wasn't in and I'll just go thank you
because I don't want to be rude yeah and
there's like well I've had one the first
time it happened I was on a red carpet
in Japan and the guy who's offering me
the photo of Elijah Wood Japanese and
did not speak English so and I didn't
speak Japanese so would you say yeah I
thought I was like I think I think I
either signed a Ledgewood or I maybe
wrote like I'm not a lighter word
um but then a guy was driving past on
the street my favorite way to get
recognized is by somebody shouting
enthusiastically from a car as they
continue on their day
um yeah it's a nice it's like oh that's
a nice moment but it doesn't nothing it
gets bigger and it's fine
um but uh this guy just like shouted out
like hey Frodo I loved a lot of the
Rings movies or something like that and
at that moment you got like he's gonna
have a really nice day if he thinks he
met Frodo so I was just like thanks man
have a good one see that's how I know
yeah that's how I know that we are
compatible because ironically in Tokyo
when I was seven years old I went there
for E.T oh well what was that like well
I was in a bathroom stall and a piece of
paper and a pen came under and they said
could you sign this and I thought
life's different yeah
yeah and did you sell any out of
interest of course right yeah always and
I take photos in the bathroom all the
time still to this day okay so our our
childhoods I think we're very affected
by Weird Al and I believe Aaron your
beautiful girlfriend
um is like how you got into him too
because I'm such a lifelong fan yeah I
mean no she I so I grew up knowing some
of Al's work in England but not being
fully indoctrinated in the way that you
just are if you grew up in America
between a certain time period you just
know him right it's so true it was it
was everyone like and no one had ever
done what he did right and it is amazing
hello in England like a lot of people
who are really into like music or comedy
really love out but here it's just
everyone like everyone's childhood was
Touched By by Weird Al at some point
you're right everyone's childhood was
touched by weird outfits very well
um and you know my girlfriend her dad's
like favorite movie is a airplane and
Naked Gun and so weird I was like Olive
and Frankie and I just watched air
I really want all films to just be like
that it's a masterpiece yeah it really
is the jokes are you know and uh when I
started dating Aaron her and her whole
family really like Weird Al became the
soundtrack to like Christmas and even
though he's only really got two
Christmas songs but we'd listen to all
of it
um and I kind of become obsessed with a
few of the songs and uh yeah to then get
the offer to play him was very surreal
but awesome I mean I think that the
message
this is not a movie that you have to go
to for a message but there is inside the
absolute deranged Insanity that this
film is
um there is a very sweet core of it
which is you know I I say in a speech
near the end of the movie like be as
weird as you want to be you know you're
only going to find true happiness when
you can accept who you truly are I think
that is something that Al really
represents for people as well he is both
smart and bizarre but also incredibly
funny and Incredibly kind and yeah it
all just like he he threads the the
needle between like yeah psychotically
insane and earnestly incredibly sweet
um in a way that I think few people do I
think that's why that's why people love
him I think and I cannot wait for this
film I'm so happy you're telling his
story that it's you telling it we're all
gonna be there I cannot wait I'm very
very honored I'm very very honored too
thank you so much thank you Daniel
Radcliffe catch him playing Weird Al and
weird the aliens
here you take it
catch me playing Weird Al and weird the
Al Yankovic story available starting
today exclusively on the Roku Channel
we'll be right back with the headlights
stick around for Drew's View
[Music]